first it's my brain dumb
i want to start with ukraine where
vladimir putin continues to show the
world he's the new hitler as he commits
monstrous genocidal barbarism against a
european democracy the deluded dictator
claims he's waging war over what he
calls the denarcification of ukraine the
truth is that what he's doing is the
nazification of ukraine and the only
difference between what hitler did in
world war ii and what putin is doing now
is that now the west is standing back
and letting him get on with it
putin thinks he's got us over a barrel
because he keeps threatening to use his
nuclear arsenal if anyone tries to stop
him and we keep recoiling in fear and
horror when he does and assuring us not
what we're going to do
well just last night he was at it again
warning that russia has weapons nobody
else has and he's ready to use them
should we intervene
but as donald trump told me early in the
week he shouldn't be allowed to throw
around the n-word as a protective shield
when he bombs maternity hospitals
targets refugees as they flee to safety
and incinerates holocaust survivors in
their homes
take a look at this clip i'm about to
show you it's a montage of some of these
atrocities going on in the ukraine it's
a hard watch but it's a much we must all
see and ask yourself one question as
you're watching what is our red line
that's what's going on here
it's genocide
at what point do we call putin's bluff
and directly engage with him to protect
the ukrainian people from yet more of
his hideous slaughter we're watching war
crimes in real time acts of depravity is
wicked as any in modern history and as
we're watching we're also sitting on the
most advanced and powerful military
force ever seen in nato
will when will enough be enough
the single argument against using
western conventional military might to
blast russia out of ukraine is fear that
it would drag us into a conflict with a
nuclear enemy and potentially trigger
world war three that's what putin wants
us to fear
he's relying on us to do nothing because
we haven't got the moral backbone to
stand up to him
but a nuclear deterrent supposed to be
there for protection
it's not a free pass for dictators to
decimate sovereign democratic countries
without fear of consequence
and putin knows if he fires one nuclear
weapon in anger he and his entire
country will be eviscerated
why would someone like him who spent his
whole life craving power and wealth and
hoardering luxury possessions risk
losing everything
if we let him win in ukraine he'll come
for more countries once a bully smells
weakness and fear they never stop
bullying and we all know that bullies
only understand one language a punch on
the nose the question really now is do
we have the guts to give him one or do
we let the brave ukrainians continue to
die in huge numbers and have their
country destroyed
the palace of westminster is a stunning
gothic monument to democracy in the
middle of london an awe-inspiring symbol
of british honor and integrity for 700
glorious years we've elected members of
parliament to defend our rights to
uphold our values and now apparently
to watch porn
yep two female mps reported an unnamed
male conservative member of parliament
for watching x-rated content on his
mobile phone as he sat in the house of
commons in full view of his colleagues
it's pretty unbelievable that any
elected official in the public purse
could be so reckless and stupid and of
course deeply insensitive to the
horrified women sitting near him but
it's also reflective of a deeper malaise
inside british politics right now three
government ministers and two opposition
lawmakers are all currently being
investigated for alleged sexual
misconduct
government officials and the prime
minister down are also being handed
police fines for breaking their own laws
to party during lockdowns
the public are entitled in my opinion to
expect higher standards of personal
probity from those they elect to run the
country when mps think it's okay to
scroll through porn on their phones as
they're supposed to be engaging in vital
parliamentary debate during a pandemic
and a european war
it's pretty clear that a dismal culture
of lavish misbehavior exists now at the
heart of british democracy and that
can't be tolerated this mp if found
guilty should be removed from parliament
talking of removal from classless to
cashless the name alex jones may not be
familiar to you until i replay an old
clip from the time he screamed at me
about guns on american television
how many gun murders were there oh
you're gonna ban your first name britain
last year
uh how many uh chimpanzees can dance on
the head of a pin the tyrants did it
hitler took the guns stalin took the
guns mal took the guns but el castro
took the gun
chavez took the guns and i'm here to
tell you 1776 will commence again if you
try to take our firearms
oh i hear you cry that crazy guy well
jones isn't just crazy he's a nasty
piece of work who built a gigantic
online following with his infowars
website and made many millions of
dollars peddling mad conspiracy theories
about the us government his most vile
claim was that the 2012 sandy hook mass
shooting was faked
very few tragedies have ever moved me
more profoundly than that appalling
massacre in which 20 children aged
between six and seven were shot dead in
their classrooms by a lone lunatic
but alex jones responded to what
happened by saying it was all a
government staged hoax perpetrated by
crisis actors to justify new gun control
laws being introduced
it was a disgusting lie that caused
immeasurable new grief and misery to the
poor families of the children who died
but 10 of those families decided to sue
him for defamation and they won and they
won big
now jones a great government conspiracy
theorist
has filed for bankruptcy as he awaits
details of the huge damages he'll now
have to pay
and he's been reduced to desperately and
pathetically beg him the same government
he has always said is the enemy of the
people for bankruptcy relief oh the
irony
jones deserves everything coming his way
what he did to those sandy hook families
was beyond despicable he's been morally
bankrupt for decades now he'll be
financially bankrupt too and hopefully
that means he'll never again be able to
lead such a vile smear campaign like the
one he did to desecrate the memory of
those 20 young
children i'm talking your children i'm
old enough to remember when disney's
sole focus was to entertain kids but now
it also wants to govern how they're
educated the reasons that completely
baffled me the family-friendly movie
company recently abandoned this historic
stance of not engaging in any partisan
politics to wage a public battle with
florida's governor and potential
presidential candidate ron desantis it's
all about a law banning schools from
teaching children as young as five about
sexual and gender preferences disney
bosses originally said they wouldn't get
involved and they were bullied into
speaking out against the supposed don't
say gay bill after many of his own angry
woke staff staged walkouts and protests
but putting aside your own opinions
about the bill itself and it doesn't
actually say by the way don't say gay
anywhere
what does have this any of this have to
do with disney
most florida parents i would guess
probably agree with desantis that they
should ultimately decide what their
young children get told about sex and
gender and if disney's really that
concerned about morality
when will we hear it stop streaming to
countries where it's illegal to be gay
or making movies in china where the
uyghur muslims are suppressed have we
heard disney speak out against the
weaker muslim suppression
have we hell
sadly this is yet another example of
corporate cowardice and hypocrisy in the
in the face of the woke mob
and i predict that disney will soon
regret ever getting involved in politics
or perhaps they'll just go the full hog
and woke wash their movies to avoid
upsetting any of their sensitive
snowflake woke force i can see the
hurriedly revised billboards now
peter pan sexual
snow mixed heritage and the seven
vertically challenged individuals
lady in the economically disadvantaged
person
and of course my personal favorite
pocahontas starring meghan markle now
you might be thinking i'll come off at
piers
but trust me there will be people at
disney right now already thinking about
it